Welcome to the deep dive.
Today we're we're stepping into
something a bit different, not
just policy analysis, but a
perspective framed with these
really, really vivid metaphors.
Yeah, almost visceral, you could
say.
Exactly.
The core idea from our source
today is that sometimes, you
know, medicine isn't about
gentle antibiotics.
Sometimes it's about the
scalpel.
Unnecessary intervention.
And that's how our source
material called Cutting Out the
Rod positions a potential second
term for Donald Trump, not as
standard politics, but as well
critical surgery on the American
Republic itself.
It's a really striking image
right off the bat, isn't it?
It immediately shifts the frame
from, say, legislative debates
to something much more
fundamental.
A full blown surgical theater
metaphor for how government
might operate.
It absolutely is, and what jumps
out, I think, is how different
the source claims this approach
would be compared to the first
term.
There's this immediate emphasis
on a total change in strategy.
And not just adjustments.
No, not at all.
The source wants you to see this
as a deliberate, almost clinical
rethinking of how power might be
used.
The language itself, it sets a
very serious, very decisive tone
from the get go.
Moving from what it calls a more
chaotic first run.
To something, it presents as far
more calculated, surgically
precise.
Perhaps keeping with their
metaphor, it really hammers home
that this is conceptualized as a
completely new approach to
governing.
Right.
So our mission today for you
listening is to really unpack
this specific viewpoint from
cutting out the rot.
We're going to dig into its main
arguments, look at who or what
it actually targets, and it's
broader than you might.
Think much broader than just
federal agencies.
Yeah.
And the methods it describes,
retty, drastic methods.
Frankly, our goal is to pull out
the key insights, the suprising
bits, the core narrative, so you
get a solid understanding of
this particular perspective
without getting lost in the,
well, the intensity of it all.
It's about understanding the
source's view why its proponents
argue it's necessary.
Exactly understanding the why
from their perspective.
So the source really dives right
in with this medical analogy.
It argues, look, sometimes icing
a knee just won't cut it.
The damage is too deep.
The antibiotics won't clear the
infection.
Right, you need surgery.
And the source states point
blank, Donald J Trump's second
term is that surgery.
It's not subtle.
No, it's not.
And what's fascinating there, if
you think about the underlying
assumption, is the idea that the
system itself is portrayed as
being so fundamentally sick.
That it needs cutting out, not
fixing.
Precisely, it implies this deep
pervasive rot, to use their
term, that conventional
politics, legislation, reform,
none of that can touch it from
this.
Viewpoint.
So only drastic painful measures
will do.
Irreversible measures, even.
That's the implication.
We're not talking minor
adjustments here.
We're talking excision
amputation, as the source leader
calls it.
And the imagery gets it's even
stronger.
It contrasts this proposed
second term, the surgery, with
what it describes, maybe a bit
mockingly, as the swaggering
improv comedy Seat of the Pants
First term.
Like a disruption that didn't
have a clear follow through.
Yeah, like someone crashing a
party but not really changing
the venue.
The second term, the Source,
paints a picture of a leader
returning with a scalpel in one
hand and a blowtorch in the
other.
You can almost picture that,
can't you?
Scalble for cutting low torch
for.
Cauterizing, maybe, ensuring it
doesn't grow back.
The mission, it says, is to cut
out what he calls the rot and
flesh out what his people call
the moles.
That blowtorch image is potent.
It suggests not just removal,
but a kind of ruthless minality.
No chance of recurrence it.
Really underscores this shift
from just disruption to
something the source sees as a
systematic dismantling.
Exactly, the metaphor implies
the patient the Republic is so
I'll that anything less than
this aggressive surgery would
just be, you know, managing
symptoms while the underlying
disease gets worse.
It's a very stark view of
governance which.
Leads us straight into why the
source argues this is necessary.
It flat out states that the
first term, well, it didn't do
it.
Didn't achieve the goal.
Right, it says.
Trump left the choir in place,
didn't purge the ranks, didn't
fire everyone who, from this
perspective, needed firing.
This is presented as a key
lesson learned.
It perceives failure that
informs the new strategy.
Definitely, the source claims
this entity, this thing it
called the intercom.
We'll get to that.
It just waited him out so.
The implication is that a less
confrontational, maybe less
systematic approach just didn't
work against what the source
portrays is this entrenched
system.
It just absorb the shock and
carried on.
That narrative really sets the
stage for the aggression
described for a second term.
It paints this picture of the
bureaucracy or this intercom, as
not just resilient but actively
resistant, almost like its own
Organism.
Yeah, like something with its
own survival instinct.
It weathered the storm,
according to the source, by just
enduring it bidding its time.
And because of that perceived
resilience, the source argues, a
much tougher, more systematic
approach is needed this time.
It's an interesting view of
bureaucratic power, less as just
people doing jobs, more as this
self healing entity that needs
to be taken apart.
Not just, you know, worked
around.
It justifies the radical means
by framing the target as
exceptionally resistant.
The source drives this home by
claiming that when the Biden
administration came in, they
just plugged the phones back in,
rehired the bench players, and
went right back to running the
show.
Business as usual resumed,
essentially.
So from the sources viewpoint,
the first term was like an
incomplete revolution, a
disruption that ultimately
didn't stick.
Which then, in this narrative,
sets the stage for something
much more thorough, more
systematic, more aggressive,
really.
The argument is basically the
failure to cut deep enough the
first time allowed the rot to
spread, making the surgery even
more urgent now.
Yeah, OK, so let's talk about
the target of this so-called
surgery.
The force introduces this key
term, the intercom.
What is that exactly?
Well, it's crucial to understand
this isn't just one agency.
It's presented as the sprawling,
interconnected network that's
the main target.
Sprawling is right.
The source calls it a network of
Ng OS media organs, State
Department adjacencies, US side
soft power tentacles, public
private influence, laundromats.
It's a real mouthful.
It is, but it tells you
immediately that the scope from
this perspective goes way beyond
just government buildings in DC.
It reaches into civil society,
media, international relations.
Things many people might see as
separate from the core
government functions.
Exactly.
And that raises a key point.
The source isn't just focused on
bureaucrats, it's targeting this
whole ecosystem.
It labels the intercom.
An ecosystem of influence.
That's how it's framed,
operating behind the scenes,
shaping narratives, wielding
power in ways that aren't always
obvious.
Breaking down the components Ng
OS Media USA helps you visualize
just how broad this target is.
It's.
Not just one department head
they're talking about replacing.
No, it's about dismantling, or
at least depowering, an entire
web of perceived influence.
And within this intercom, the
source talks about individuals
it labels moles working towards
subversion is the term used.
Right.
And the claim is pretty stark
that the entire executive
branch, from DOJ to state to the
Pentagon's upper ranks, is shot
through with loyalists to an
opposing ideology.
That language shot through
loyalists opposing ideology.
It's very confrontational.
It frames it not as
disagreement, but as internal
opposition, like an enemy
within.
Yeah, it's just active betrayal,
ideological warfare happening
inside the institutions.
Which politically is a very
potent claim.
Hugely potent, the mole concept
transforms political opposition
into something closer to, well,
espionage or sabotage from the
inside.
So.
It's not just policy
differences.
Not according to this source.
It's presented as a deliberate
hidden undermining.
The idea that whole departments
are filled with people loyal to
an opposing ideology basically
reframes governance itself as a
constant battle against internal
enemies.
And that perception, whether
accurate or not, becomes the
justification for the extreme
measures the source then
proposes.
It paints a picture of a system
so compromised it needs purging.
So, OK, how would this actually
happen?
This scorched earth doctrine, as
the source calls it, it brings
up the Elon Musk fire half the
company model.
Yeah, that comparison is very
deliberate.
The source claims that
hypothetically, within weeks of
retaking the White House, Trump
began executing a plan that
looks like the Elon Musk fire
half the company model, but
applied to government.
Applied to federal agencies,
NGOs and grant pipelines, not
just tech workers.
Which suggests something very
fast, very large scale, not
targeted removals based on
individual performance reviews.
Right.
It implies a broad systematic
reduction and using that private
sector analogy, the must
comparison suggests efficiency,
speed, maybe even a certain
ruthlessness in restructuring
government.
And the source gets specific
about the mechanics.
Talks about mass terminations at
the Department of Justice, State
Department, USAID.
And it mentions voluntary
retirement that weren't
voluntary, right?
Plus.
Contractors sent packing, entire
NGO budgets zeroed out.
It sounds less like trimming the
fat and more like.
A deliberate dismantling.
And what's key here, I think, is
how the source contrasts the
official reason budget cuts with
the unofficial reality.
It presents a perch.
A duality of purpose stated
versus actual intent.
Exactly.
It paints a picture of a
strategy designed for immediate,
significant impact across
specific institutions, using
budget mechanisms as the tool,
or perhaps the cover for a
deeper ideological goal.
And this goes beyond just
government employees, right?
The source makes that.
Clear.
Oh, absolutely.
It explicitly mentions
shuttering USA projects, pulling
grants from public media, axing
State Department cultural
outreach programs, zeroing out
funding for advocacy NGOs.
So for you listening, this means
that from the perspective laid
out in Cutting out the Rot, even
organizations you might think of
as non political or even
beneficial like public media or
cultural programs.
They're seen as part of the
problem part of this intercom.
And therefore targets for
defunding.
It's hitting the whole
ecosystem, America's soft power,
foreign aid and NGO ecosystem,
as the source puts it.
And connecting that to the
bigger picture, the framing is
explicit.
It's about cutting off the
oxygen that keeps the other
side's infrastructure live.
Not just stopping a program, but
starving the network.
Precisely.
And the source even names names
NPR, PBS, the Corporation for
Public Broadcasting, saying
they'd lose their sugar supply.
Which shows just how broad the
targeting is conceived to be in
this document.
It extends to institutions
central to public information
and culture.
It really underscores the view
that these entities are
considered integral parts of
this intercom and subject to the
same surgical approach of really
comprehensive strategies being
described.
So what's the real motivation
here?
According to the source, it says
explicitly it's not just about
saving money.
No, this isn't presented as a
primarily fiscal move.
It's about depowering the
intercom, the complex of
institutions that Trump and his
base see as the enemy within.
That's pretty blunt.
Very blunt.
It centers the motivations
squarely on power, control and
ideology, not economics.
It frames these actions as
strategic maneuvers to
neutralize opposition.
Which raises that big question,
how is this conflict perceived?
The source frames it as almost
self-defense, right survival
politics.
Yes, exactly.
Not just a policy preference,
but an imperative.
The justification given is
powerful.
The idea that taxpayer dollars
were funding their own
opposition.
That's the core grievance
expressed federal grants
bankrolling NGO's that produce
anti Trump narratives, USAID and
state programs propping up
causes that bleed back into
domestic politics.
So it.
Explains this deep sense of
betrayal, this perception that
public funds are being misused
to attack the very
administration providing them.
Which in turn justifies the
purge as a corrective measure,
turning off that constant hum of
the opposition's messaging, as
the source puts it.
It's framed as stopping a system
that's working against itself,
or at least against the elected
administration's interest.
And the source really double s
down on the severity.
It concludes this part by
stating this isn't reform, it's
amputation.
That word again.
Amputation.
And it goes further.
It says every firing, every
dismantled program, even every
protester.
That's not Democratic pushback.
That's a signal, a message
proving the purge is necessary.
This is a.
Fascinating interpretation of
dissent, isn't it?
It flips it.
Instead of opposition being a
reason to reconsider, it's
presented as a validation that
you're hitting the right
targets.
The louder the screams, the more
necessary the surgery is
perceived to be.
It implies irreversible changes
needed for the Republic to
survive from this viewpoint.
A very aggressive stance, it
positions protests not as
legitimate debate but as
confirmation that the rot is
being effectively attacked.
Now, Speaking of opposition, the
source makes a really specific
point about who it sees
protesting this hypothetical
purge.
Yeah, it notes a perceived
paradox.
It says the opposition isn't,
you know, farmers in denim
overalls or angry working class
union men.
Not a grassroots uprising for
outside the system.
No, instead, it claims the
protesters in DC are almost all
current former or retired
government lifers, NGO
directors, agency lawyers, think
tank fellows.
People from within or adjacent
to the very system being
targeted.
And it adds pointedly, and they
are without exception white.
OK, let's unpack that.
The source is pointing to what
it sees as this ironic
disconnect.
The people defending the machine
are, in its view, drawing their
livelihood from it.
It's a rhetorical move to
undermine the legitimacy of the
protests, to paint it as
self-interest, not principled
opposition.
The palace guards rioting
against the king while still
cashing the King's paychecks is
the analogy used.
A very theatrical framing.
It is.
It suggests hypocrisy.
It reinforces the idea that the
intercom is self-serving and
those protesting are just
protecting their own turf, not
some higher principle.
So it defines the opposition in
a way that allows their
objections to be dismissed
within this narrative.
The revolutionaries versus the
establishment protecting itself.
And this idea leads directly
into a specific story the source
uses as a kind of case study to
make the Moles idea concrete.
Right, the Sean Dunn anecdote.
Exactly.
The source describes it vividly.
Sean Dunn, a Department of
Justice trial lawyer paid by the
taxpayers, sworn to uphold the
Constitution, square up against
federal agents and hurl Subway
sandwich while yelling fascist.
And the source insists this is
not a cartoon.
This happened.
It presents this as a perfect
microcosm of the conflict and
arrow Boros of governance.
The federal government calling
the federal government fascist.
The system eating itself.
It's a striking, almost absurd
image designed to make that
abstract idea of internal
conflict feel very real.
Very real, very tangible, and it
details the supposed
consequence.
Judge Jeanine Pirro's swift
response.
Felony charges.
Job terminated.
So this specific incident
becomes the proof, the
illustration of the mole concept
in action, evidence of that
internal ideological war.
It's presented as the moment
where the government is openly
at war with itself.
Not just theory, but an actual
event symbolizing this deep rot
from the source's perspective.
And the source uses this to
bolster its broader point.
It views Dunn and others like
him as Mole's agents embedded
inside the apparatus working
toward its subversion.
And critically, it adds that
whether that assessment is
objectively fair or not almost
doesn't matter.
What matters for this viewpoint
is the perception that the
entire executive branch is shot
through with loyalists to an
opposing ideology.
So the incident becomes symbolic
proof that justifies the whole
purge strategy described
earlier.
It's not an anomaly, it's
evident to the core problem.
Exactly.
It serves as justification for
those drastic measures.
This brings us to how the source
describes this strategic
thinking behind this potential
second term approach.
It talks about the deeper lesson
of the full Me Once theory of
political insurgency.
Right.
It contrasts the feeling of
being a revolutionary with the
reality of governing.
Being a revolutionary, it says,
is intoxicating.
Always on offense, everything
feels like a win.
But governing?
That's exhausting.
Requires compromise,
administration, patience, things
the source suggests
revolutionaries aren't typically
good at or interested in.
So it explains this evolution
from what it saw as a chaotic
first term to what it describes
as a disciplined, maybe even
occupation style second term.
A lesson learned.
That shift is really central to
the whole argument from
spontaneous disruption to a
calculated methodical approach.
First term breaks things, Second
term systematically dismantles
and rebuilds differently.
And the goal of this second
phase?
The source is blunt.
Trump's first term was the
revolution.
His second is the occupation.
Not fighting in the streets,
but.
Ensure the establishments desks
are empty.
It implies this focus on
changing the structure from
within and administrative
dismantling, not necessarily
public clashes.
A quieter but maybe more
profound transformation through
internal means pulling out the
roots, not just trimming the
branches.
So for you, the listener, the
source is really suggesting this
shift from visible rebellion to
a kind of internal siege.
Less about rallies, more about
systematically removing
perceived opposition from their
positions, cutting their
funding.
Changing the government's
function and ideology from the
inside out by removing those
structural impediments as the
source sees them.
And this ties back to the
intercom idea.
The source expands on that
metaphor.
It does.
It calls it a massive invisible
PA system, broadcasting a
particular ideological tone not
just overseas, but beaming back
into the.
US designed for influence, not
accountability.
That's key.
It reinforces that the described
purge is about controlling
narratives, controlling
ideology, not just saving money.
It links soft power directly to
domestic political impact.
And dismantling it is framed as
survival politics silencing that
internal broadcast.
Necessary from their viewpoint
to even be able to govern
effectively.
And that imagery gets really
intense again.
Dismantling the intercom is
framed as cutting off the oxygen
that keeps the other side's
infrastructure alive.
It's a very strong, almost
violent metaphor.
It suggests this isn't just
about winning debates, but about
permanently silencing certain
voices by taking away their
means of operating, their
funding, their platforms.
Because that infrastructure is
seen as an existential threat to
the administration described in
the source, it has to be
eliminated from this perspective
so the other side can't
effectively function or
communicate.
And the source brings it all
full circle back to that initial
medical metaphor.
Doesn't it?
It really does.
It concludes by reiterating the
rot wasn't scraped out in
20/17/2021, so it metastasized.
Implying the first term wasn't
aggressive enough.
Right.
And now, now it's surgery with
no anesthesia.
No anesthesia.
That's Stark.
It implies a complete disregard
for minimizing pain or
disruption.
It's seen as a necessary part of
the cure.
The final instruction is cut
deep, cut fast and cauterize the
wound before the patient.
The Republic wakes up screaming.
Wow, that final image really
hammers on the message of
extreme, urgent and maybe even
brutal action being seen as
necessary for survival,
according to this source.
The idea is to get the surgery
done before resistance can fully
mobilize to ensure the perceived
cure takes hold whether the
patient likes it or not at the
time.
Well, we've certainly dug deep
into cutting out the rot.
Today.
We've explored this really vivid
perspective, this shift from
political antibiotics to surgery
without anesthesia.
Moving beyond what it called the
improv comedy first term to a
scorched earth doctrine.
We identified the intercom, that
whole network of NGOs, media,
government linked groups as the
target aiming to flesh out
perceived moles.
And we looked at the motivation
presented, this idea that
taxpayer money was funding the
opposition, necessitating mass
terminations, budget cuts,
dismantling soft power
infrastructure.
All frames not as reform but as
amputation, seen by the sources
proponents as vital for the
Republic's survival.
It's a perspective that really
does challenge our usual ideas
about how government functions,
about stability and continuity.
Definitely.
It reframes the relationship
between an administration and
the bureaucracy as internal
warfare.
And if government is seen as
this uroboros fighting itself,
one part trying to amputate
another, well, what does that
imply for public service, for
loyalty, for political division?
It's a heavy thought.
If parts of the government are
perceived as the enemy within,
what kind of institution results
from that kind of reordering?
And what's it like for the
people working inside?
Yeah, when your role becomes
that politicized, that fraught,
what does that future look like?
It certainly leaves you thinking
about the long term effects of
redefining governance in such
drastic terms.
We hope this deep dive gave you
a clear understanding of this
specific intense viewpoint from
the source material.
Some valuable context,
hopefully.
Thanks for joining us on the
Deep Dive.